Namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma sambodassam Namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma sambodassam Namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma sambodassam
homage to the Buddha the blessed noble and fully self-enlightened one so we've been through the first two noble truths and the first one of course was telling us what suffering what the Buddha means by suffering and the second one was the as it's translated the origin of suffering the arising of suffering or the cause of suffering I mean that's the better
better translation, the cause of suffering.
What is the original beginning of how suffering arises.
And so he goes on, he says, well perhaps I could read that, it's very short.
Now this, monks, is the noble truth of suffering.
Birth is suffering, aging is suffering, illness is suffering, death is suffering, union with what is displeasing is suffering, separation from what is pleasing is suffering,
is suffering, not to get what one wants is suffering.
In brief, the five aggregates of clinging are suffering.
Now this, monks, is the noble truth of the origin of suffering.
It is this craving that leads to renewed existence, accompanied by delight and lust-seeking delight here and there.
That is, craving for sensual pleasure, craving for existence, craving for extermination.
So this is the third one.
Now this, monks, is the noble truth of the cessation of suffering.
it is the remainderless fading away and cessation of that same craving the giving up and relinquishing of it freedom from it non-attachment so first of all there's this amazing statement that there is an end to suffering I don't think any in the West any modern psychologist would ever think of that
they think of an accommodation being able to be generally at ease with the way things are but the end of fear I have a book which is a sort of companion to the book Emotional Intelligence Intelligent Emotion it's called and in the preface she says there will always be fear there will always be anxiety so there's no
There's no conception in Western psychology, in Western psychotherapy, that there's an actual place where suffering actually comes to an end.
Even in our religions, the Abrahamic religions, the end of suffering is in heaven.
That's where you go.
There's no way you can end suffering in this life, as far as I understand.
Perhaps the saints do, but it's generally understood it comes afterwards.
It comes when you get to heaven
Now, of course, in Buddhist understanding, it takes quite a while to get to this point where there's an end of suffering.
But the statement is you can do it right here and now as a human being.
So this is quite, to me, it's always amazingly radical that there can be right here and now this end of suffering.
And he says it's the remainderless fading away and cessation of that same craving.
the giving up and relinquishing of it, freedom from it, non-attachment.
So he centers the whole of his teaching concerning the end of suffering on this point of craving.
Now you've got to remember that he's pointing to the word tanha, right?
Upadana, tanha upadana.
These two words are telling us about our psychology when it comes to seeking happiness, right?
There's a seeking happiness in the world and of course the world can't deliver.
That's the point.
The world cannot deliver perfect peace and happiness.
Even if it's on the simple grounds that things arise and pass away.
So as soon as you've got something, you know, you'd like to say stop the world, but it doesn't happen.
And this craving, this craving and this grasping of the five aggregates, these
this body-mind complex, and the grasping of it, remember, is that suggestion of identity.
So in this he's basically saying not until the identity passes, this same craving.
Remember in the second noble truth he says it's the craving for existence, craving for extermination, but the suffering itself,
is the five aggregates subject to clinging so that clinging remember is Upadhyāna this business of identifying with the body and heart and mind and because we identify with that we seek happiness as a product of that body of that psycho-physical organism and that's why it'll always fail so he says when that completely passes away
when that desire to seek permanent happiness this happiness in the world passes away there's a complete non-attachment to it and so here his formulation is very is in that via negativa you know the way in which you say what something is by saying what it isn't so in the state of enlightenment state of liberation right and
here the big word is non-attachment in that state of liberation from craving liberation from wrong identity there is this end of suffering so you have to be careful that therefore there's not an interpretation of that in a very negative sense that there's nothing there anyway that's the end of it you enter into this blank, this cessation you'll come across these words like nirodha
the end of suffering meaning some sort of complete cessation remember when christian missionaries first came across buddhism they interpreted that just as a sort of clever way of annihilation since the since the since there was no self there was no self to be to be saved and therefore when you were liberated you were basically it was a sort of subtle form of annihilation so you've always got to counterbalance that with these
very clear statements the Buddha makes about Nibbāna.
He doesn't say Nibbāna here.
He's keeping clear of that word for the moment.
He's just telling us what's not there.
Of course, in later, when he talks about end of suffering later, he says it's Nibbāna.
And that Nibbāna translates as no desire, but it also translates as not shackled, not shackled, not binding.
And this refers to something within us
which no longer attaches to the world you see and that's referring back to this awareness this satipaṋña this awareness this intuitive awareness and again he has various ways of pointing to that in that negative way there is an unborn undying this is it should be not born not dying not compounded not conditioned right and remember that
I think I've said this before, the word he uses when he talks about that is a specific word in Pali which really translates as best as there exists.
So there's two words for is, hoti and ati.
Hoti is what we would normally use for something like this is a book or there is a book in the other room.
But ati translates much stronger, it's actually an existence.
There exists, not born, not that.
then he talks about it as an āyatana which is a sphere and remember in his language there are six spheres of experience which relate to the five basic senses and the mind as a sense base so these create spheres which are not they don't interfere with each other you can't see through your ears then he talks about there is a sphere
where none of that exists where there's no moon no sun etc etc and then he has lovely words like the island the refuge home things like that all suggesting something very positive about that particular experience so whenever you read you know the scriptures you always have to remember that his approach to what is
for want of a better word, transcendent, but remember it's right here and now, so it's also imminent.
It's right here and now, this possibility.
His preferred way of expressing it is by telling us what it isn't.
You have to be careful that in so doing you don't translate it as something which just doesn't exist.
It's some form of a clever way of telling us that we're going to be annihilated because there's no self.
therefore when you get rid of the self there's nobody there but that wouldn't be correct so keeping that in mind you see in this particular first discourse where he's first of all expounding for the first time his understanding he keeps it very simple he states that the cause of suffering is this desire this attachment this identity
and it's when this completely fades away that there is this non-attachment so that non-attachment equals the end of suffering equals Nibbāna and when he's questioned because of this way of expressing Nibbāna always in the negative sense even in his time he is accused of being an annihilationist
and he constantly says the only things to be annihilated are greed hatred and delusion greed hatred and delusion and the delusion remember refers to this identity we have with this psychophysical organism human being so when you're reading the scriptures like this you know we always have to remember that he's always his preferred way of
of talking about that which is transcendent of this world, is always in this negative sense.
So this, monks, is the noble truth of the cessation of suffering, the end of suffering, the complete end of suffering.
It is the remainderless, there's nothing left, fading away, and cessation, complete ending of that same craving, the giving up and relinquishing of it, freedom from it, non-attachment.
I can only hope my words have convinced you that there is an end to suffering and that you will attain that sooner or later.